[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's first get the obvious out of
the way nothing beats a high quality
acoustic piano
that being said my super general
statement is that any piano
that you enjoy playing and that will
bring you back to the piano is a great
piano to work on so the only piano that
i truly own is this kawaii digital piano
it's not the best quality
the touch is a little funky but it's
weighted and graded and that's what
matters to me so i enjoy playing this
piano for a variety of reasons most of
it's personal because i've grown
attached to it but some are very
specific reasons for example i could use
headphones
and i could play at any hour of the day
without bothering people around me of
course if you're playing really heavily
there's that clunky noise but it's not
another little thing is that you don't
have to tune this ever so for me
personally i do a very specific type of
work on this piano studying scores
memorizing music learning notes to a
certain extent using this as a midi
keyboard or whatever usb keyboard and
just fooling around on it on my own
terms now for classical repertoire like
i said those specific reasons i don't
really practice anything delicate or i
need to be focused on getting a very
sensitive touch
obviously the the quality of the sound
is just not there it's not the same now
comparing digital acoustic that's just
pointless because
acoustic is better
it depends on what you're comparing and
for what you're comparing it right i
think it's sort of similar to having a
tablet with a very high quality stylus
this is a real pen but just as an
example even the best best best tablets
out there where you can simulate drawing
and painting it's just not the same
experience so in the past when i'm
learning a very difficult repertoire or
repertoire that i really
need to learn but i don't want to learn
that sort of thing i would get on this
piano
put the volume very low and then learn
it that way where i could hear it i know
what i'm doing to a certain extent but i
wouldn't have to listen to myself
practicing it at a real volume
so i would do something like this
[Music]
i could hear it enough but
it doesn't really bother me and i know
that's that's terrible but that's just
the truth
sometimes i would record something
maybe like a loop then i would just play
it back
i make sure to put the touch
so that's really heavy the heaviest
setting i don't really care for
all these so that's it i really like
this digital piano it's it serves me
well and